je suis né en iran un pays de 33
millions d'habitants
je sais tout ça pas grâce à lui en tout
cas la belgique
cette viande contre la et là je m'attèle
hibat et voici mon histoire mon pays est
magnifique et le roi concerné par son
peuple
or avant mon fou à la fois mon fou moi
j'ai décidé pas m'en [ __ ]
c'est pas un jeu il bat ils vont tuer
qu'est ce qu'il veut ce qui vous fait le
plus peur aroca une démocratie et c'est
là que j'ai rencontré fait rester
elle est parfaite je suis l'épousé
alors comme ça tu es poussé ma fille
c'est quoi cet axe en 2 cv lui faire
peur non ça va je sais juste et chef du
parti pense que ça devient trop
dangereux pour nous ici on part quand
tu partirais en moi
tu as raison c'est nous 3 ou rien
je suis désolé pour tout ça
je te remercie pour tous à notre
histoire a commencé en iran
et elle se terminera en france
salut les connards
bienvenue au quartier nord de pire fuite
c'est votre centre ça vous tous a fait
rester j'aimerais que tu fasses de la
sensibilisation médicale je vais pas
demander pardon à dieu à chaque impôts
c'est de la biologie alors par faut
revoir la biologie
et battez les parties au présent titre
est battu
papa je voulais vous dire que vous reste
en france une en fait ce que vous avez à
faire
soyez reprend
ce film n'est pas inspiré d'une histoire
vraie
moi
c'est une histoire vraie